ich begrüße an dieser stelle von der
sympathischen firma mckinsey christian
mckay gehring als beratungsunternehmen
oppositionelle verpetzen ihre firma ist
aber wirklich der satan
doch er fällt sie auf mich zu
schmeicheln sie machen mich ja ganz voll
regen sah dann ist mein großes vorbild
von mir kennen sie haben für die saudis
tatsächlich untersucht wie bestimmte
sparmaßnahmen der regierung in den
sozialen netzwerken kritisiert werden
und dabei haben wir dann drei personen
identifiziert die besonders frech wird
besonders aktiv waren
in den sozialen netzwerken und
entschuldigung was dann die saudis mit
internen infos von uns anfangen ob die
ihren kritiker den orden verleihen oder
was abhaken
ja da sind wir in meine wir geht ja gar
nicht
sie sehen da gar keine verantwortung
nein verantwortung angebraten ja wir
sind ja berater wir beraten lange
tradition meint wer kennt sie schon
alles beraten hat es geht ja ganz weit
zurück kollegen von mir haben damals
könig herodes diesen
dass es da in gewissen baby überschuss
gar das waren wir also lange reihe von
top kunden dschingis khan stalin carsten
maschmeyer unit dann beraten sie
höchstwahrscheinlich auch joe kaeser den
chef von siemens der weiter gerne
geschäfte bei den saudis macht so ein
mord mich schön sagte aber und yahoo
andererseits wenn wir aufhören mit
ländern zu reden in denen menschen
vermisst werden
dann kann ich auch zu hause bleiben drei
camps bay
na dann bleib doch zuhause dieser woche
blieben er war doch zu hause am ende saß
zu hause geblieben ja und er hätte bei
dieser konferenz in riad diese woche das
muss man sich wirklich immer wieder klar
machen hätte für siemens das ist kein
witz 21 milliarden dollar auftrag
unterschreiben können und darauf
verzichten jetzt sind sie druck
der leser muss dem vertrag jetzt später
unterschreiben der muss da noch mal hin
also der bringt schon opfer für die
menschenrechte herberge reden wir nicht
drumrum die sau die sind einfach zu
reich man kann sich seine kunden nicht
aussuchen
klar kann man sich seine kunden
aussuchen und nein nicht wenn sie so
reich sind 800 deutsche unternehmen von
denen auf den saudischen markt alle
großen siemens bayer boehringer basf
linde daimler bei der liste kriege ich
eine reaktion ist ja klar es ist doch
für mich nicht zu fassen dass sich auch
unsere bundesregierung fast alle
ministerien von ihrer blüten firma
beraten lassen 40 steuermillionen ja wo
ist das problem wir helfen den bund beim
sparen schon gehört sparen kennen sie
gar nicht als zdf-mitarbeiter ja wir
erkennen wir erkennen sparpotenziale ja
hier wussten sie eigentlich dass es in
der ard auch eine satiresendung gibt
donnerstags idee warum legt man die
beiden satiresendung nicht einfach
zusammen und dann moderiert der
sympathische typ von extra 3 man was man
[Applaus]
ich glaube dass alles müll bedeckt
den applaus wenn ich ihnen nie verzeihen
christian g
[Applaus]
[Musik]